[Music]
before we go and Missouri family is
welcoming the new year with a furry new
family member and renewed hope for the
health of their youngest son it's a
heartwarming story and Adriana Diaz is
here to tell it for us Adriana good
morning good morning at just 2 years old
Truitt Palmer has undergone listen to
this 14 surgeries including a
life-saving heart transplant last
October Truitt found strength in
recovery through a therapy dog named
Azeri
that bond between boy and Goldendoodle
is part of a holiday tale which began
under desperate circumstances born with
a congenital heart defect true at palmar
faced an unclear future he was born not
breathing with no heart race
I'm the uncertainty of what life would
be like for him after birth was
terrifying but we made it through last
summer after the second of three
open-heart surgeries Truitt met Zuri of
golden doodle therapy dog at Boston
Children's Hospital we brought him so
much joy and you know it was almost like
when Zuri was in the room we forgot
about what was going on around following
a heart transplant in October true its
parents sought to adopt their own golden
doodle to help him recover then Truitt's
mom Danielle found this Facebook post
from a Kentucky breeder looking to
donate a puppy to a special needs child
when I found out that Truitt's dog in
the hospital his therapy dog was a
little female I just I was like I've got
to give it to him you know there's no
questions using a group shared plain
Truitt's dad and grandfather took off
from Missouri after nine and a half
hours round trip
Zeta grace arrived in time for a
Christmas surprise he's ready to see her
and it's just been an incredible just an
incredible blood they are being so true
it's doctors have seen no signs of
rejection of his transplanted heart a
gift of life his mother says many
children are still waiting to receive a
great story Adrianna do we know what
happened to the other puppies so the
breeder Geno gray said that she was so
inspired by chuwit store that she wanted
to help other children so two puppies
are going to two other children that are
battling health issues it's a beautiful
thing that is amazing that you've got to
give it to true it's parents who've
who've worked so hard and I hear through
all this and and I love that that true
it's dad and grandfather flew down
that's right they get the puppy that's
just an amazing it was actually the
grandfather who saw the post on Facebook
from the reader and made that connection
and these are expensive dogs yes I was
probably thousands of dollars in this
family got it for free yeah I love it
miracle of modern medicine and also of
the miracle of puppy therapy that's the
powerful combination all right great way
to start the new year Adrianna thank you
you